[Music]
on this Saturday night the big morale
boost for Ukraine Russia's only road to
Crimea collapses this is all Putin can
do now is rattle his nuclear saber plus
the fears over Putin's next play more
protests in Iran and Canada as Western
pressure increases deadly heat and
record-setting droughts it is an
absolutely dire situation the worries
over water as dead fish pile up in BC
and from a small living room to a turkey
Warehouse she haulers we run meet Maria
the Thanksgiving angel
yeah
global national with Farah Nasser
[Music]
a huge explosion on the only Bridge
connecting Mainland Russia with Russian
occupied Crimea partially collapsing a
key Supply route from moscow's military
and its ongoing war on Ukraine Russian
officials say three people were killed
on the Kirch Strait bridge in what
appears to be a truck bomb attack
Ukraine hasn't claimed direct
responsibility
now this isn't just a logistical blow to
the Kremlin it's deeply symbolic a
humiliating defeat for Vladimir Putin
himself happening a day after his 70th
birthday on one of his most prized
infrastructure projects that he himself
unveiled in 2018.
ukrainians didn't wait long to
commemorate the apparent attack mere
hours later people were already posing
and taking selfies in front of a
billboard showing what appears to be a
new stamp depicting the Bridge's
destruction and monobank that's
Ukraine's second largest bank says it's
already issuing this debit card design
showing the same thing
and a short time ago Ukrainian president
velodimir zielinski made an apparent
reference to the bridge blast during his
nightly video address describing Crimea
as cloudy but warm today
good evening and thank you for joining
us this moment in the war is being met
with mixed emotion a day of Jubilation
in Ukraine but hanging over that there
and around the world the feeling of fear
over Russia's retaliation and as
Jennifer Johnson reports it could lead
to a major escalation even in the coming
days to a conflict that's already
heating up from both sides
Ukrainian officials have repeatedly
threatened to strike the much hated
bridge to cut off one of Russia's major
Supply arteries into their country but
Ukraine is not claim responsibility for
the bombing some Russian lawmakers are
calling on President Vladimir Putin to
retaliate as Ukrainian forces continue
to reclaim territory once controlled by
the Kremlin the way his military has
performed in this war
is not indicative of a major superpower
Russia has now named a new military
commander to lead its war effort as some
Russian forces are reportedly fleeing
battle areas military experts say now is
the time for world leaders to step up
and further Aid Ukraine in the next one
to three months the Americans and all of
the NATO allies will continue to provide
as much support to the ukrainians as
possible the intention is to help them
retake as much territory as they can
meanwhile both sides are trading blame
for shelling overnight near Ukraine's
Russian occupied nuclear power plant the
largest in Europe the plan is now using
emergency diesel generators to Power
Cooling and safety functions for as long
as 10 days to avoid a potential nuclear
disaster plant Engineers are racing to
repair the plant's power line
but Putin's losses are mounting
some military experts concern he may
resort to using short-range nuclear
weapons to try and win this war this is
all Putin can do now is rattle his
nuclear saber and I think he has to know
that if he uses a nuclear weapon the
consequences would be unbearable for him
the top Republican of the U.S House
Foreign Affairs committee is calling on
world powers to try and reason with
Putin I think every nation in in the
United Nations needs to warn Putin this
will not be tolerated including the
Nations that have stayed on the
sidelines but Putin is showing no sign
of backing down and there is growing
concern the bombing of the bridge an
embarrassing blow to him may lead to
further aggression against Ukraine
Jennifer Johnson Global News Washington
more deadly protests erupted across Iran
today against the regime's deeply
entrenched religious dress codes and
brutality against women outrage is
growing on multiple fronts the new
coroners report claiming Masa amini died
from organ failure not blows to her body
and the deaths of two teenage girls
Serena Ismail zadeh Anika shakurami
reportedly killed by the country's
Security Forces during the ongoing
demonstrations that have entered a
fourth week at least two more protesters
were reportedly killed by Security
Forces today
[Applause]
and large crowds gathered in Vancouver
and Toronto today protesting for the
rights of Iranian women it comes after
prime minister Justin Trudeau demanded
an end to the Iranian government's
Crackdown on the mass protests
announcing new sanctions and a freeze of
Canadian held assets Iran denies
security forces are responsible for the
deaths of amini or the two teenagers but
the situation is painting a dark picture
of the dangers for those standing up and
speaking out
British Columbia at this time of year is
normally cool and wet deserving its
reputation as the wet Coast but this
year things are pretty different just
yesterday 19 temperature records were
shattered across the province The Hot
Spot of Canada was in Squamish hitting
nearly 30 degrees as David Aiken reports
much of the province has seen little
rain since July and is facing serious
drought conditions already disrupting
the Region's fishery and agricultural
activities
up and down British Columbia's Coast
water levels are running dangerously low
it is an absolutely dire situation Ruth
Foster has worked with a coastal salmon
hatchery since the 1970s and she says
these Creeks should be filled with water
and with salmon swimming up them to
spawn instead creek beds are dry and
filled with Boulders what we're
concerned about right now are Coho
returning to all these small coastal
streams that are lacking water right now
for coho salmon the clock is ticking
without access to these streams they may
die without spawning these mostly pink
salmon try to ascend a creek near Bella
Bella thousands perished when the creek
dried up ever seen it kind of across the
territory and I think throughout the BBC
Coast so it's kind of unprecedented
conditions right now the drought could
have an impact on BC Fisheries for years
to come we've been on a steady decline
for a long time and situations like this
don't help the overall health of the
stocks of seven that's for sure but it's
not just the fishery agricultural
activities throughout the province are
suffering from the lack of rain but it's
most serious on Vancouver Island and
BC's Lower Mainland where provincial
officials have put the drought at level
four or more serious level five which
means adverse impacts are almost certain
in order for the drug and we're actually
going to need some pretty strong
impactful storms and and dare I say
atmospheric Rivers will will will be
needed to actually end the drought
communities throughout the province are
implementing conservation measures
including bans on all outdoor water use
it is most serious in a handful of towns
on BC's Sunshine Coast where the lake
that is the source of Municipal Water is
all but drying up we're losing their
capacity to provide residents with water
um
that we're not able to provide enough
water to our hospital as well as for
firefighting and the forecast for
southwestern BC may be a chance of
showers on Monday followed by more heat
and more sun David Aiken Global News
from droughts that threaten Water
Supplies to devastating floods hundreds
of millions of people are now facing
these new and ongoing climate threats as
ready zucchini explains a new studies
warning that catastrophic scorching heat
events they used to play out once every
few hundred years are becoming much more
frequent
cracked Landscapes under a blistering
Sun became a trademark image during the
summer of 2022 and across much of the
northern hemisphere from the U.S desert
to the parched shores of China's Yangtze
River extreme droughts endangered
economies and lives we are already
seeing the Fingerprints of climate
change in the uh the drought that we've
seen and climate change is already
hitting us hard science has proven the
world is warming and the new study from
the world weather attribution group
Finds Its resulting in drier land
scientists determined this by looking at
water levels in soil suggesting human
emissions which are raising the global
temperature have resulted in some of the
most severe soil moisture droughts on
record the events
was made at least 20 times more likely
due to human induced climate change
at its most basic finding droughts that
were once in a 400 year event might now
repeat every 20 years we have time to
influence the trade trajectory of our
climate system and yet we know that
based on where we are on that trajectory
we really only have about eight years
before we start to see some of those
negative consequences climate change
is already ravaging the world it's not
hypothetical it's not a hypothetical
threat 2022's droughts would be an issue
on their own but factored in with the
global food and energy crisis caused by
the war in Ukraine the situation was
only exacerbated I like to think of
climate change as a threat multiplier so
whatever kinds of threats we're facing
as a planet as a nation as a family
climate change is going to ramp those up
the study's authors do acknowledge that
climate change can't be blamed for
everything sometimes Solutions
themselves pose problems take flood
mitigation that sends water out to sea
rather than tanks to offset drought
there are going to be constraints and
limits to adaptation that we'll face
dealing with these complexities going
forward
complexities that scientists fear could
result in Perpetual or even permanent
droughts if action isn't taken
Reggie chicken Global News Washington
new details are emerging and a sexual
assault Scandal involving police
officers in Newfoundland and Labrador a
lawsuit filed on behalf of seven women
in St John's outlines a range of
violations between the years
2001-2017 and the impact the assaults
had on the alleged victims Ross Lorde
reports
the allegations are shocking that for
years uniformed officers with the Royal
Newfoundland constabulary were offering
to drive women home from downtown St
John's and instead sexually assaulted
them this was a horrible violation of
trust these women got in the cars with
the police officers because they were
police officers and the officers abused
that trust it's it's really really
disturbing some of the allegations were
exposed in court when a judge sentenced
Constable Doug snelgrove to four years
in prison for sexually assaulting a
woman at her home while on duty but a
lawsuit filed in the Supreme Court of
Newfoundland and Labrador suggests
Snellgrove was not an isolated example
it claims seven women were sexually
assaulted from unwanted kissing to
forced intercourse by on-duty RNC
members the lawsuit claims the women
have chronically suffered acute and
irreparable psychological harm and other
severe impairments and disabilities
including substance abuse loss of
enjoyment of life and humiliation and
betrayal due to having been sexually
battered the lawsuit says the women are
owed aggravated and punitive damages in
addition to other damages I think that
there is a culture of misogyny uh within
the RNC and I do not believe that steps
are being taken to address that culture
in an email statement the constabulary
said the RNC holds its officers and
civilian staff to the highest standard
of Integrity respect and professionalism
the RNC quietly changed a policy last
year so that officers can only offer
drives to members of the public as part
of a service call that's officially
documented the extent of the abuse is
unclear the clergy the sexual abuse
Scandal started in Newfoundland and
Labrador as well with Mount Castle in
the 80s and I hope that this is not a
canada-wide problem but it certainly is
a problem that we're we've been seeing a
lot of here in Newfoundland Labrador she
expects more women to come forward in a
scandal that's still evolving
Ross Lord Global News
coming up Jason
ly concerned about the
[Music]
plus how one Calgary woman is giving
back to those in need this Thanksgiving
weekend
Danielle Smith has been Alberta's
Premier designate for just a few days
and she's now campaigning for a seat in
the legislature after announcing her
intentions today but before her party
win this week she was already ramping up
rhetoric appealing to controversial
ideas involving Alberta sovereignty
while endorsing baseless conspiracy
theories a direction that even outgoing
Premier Jason Kenney admits he's not
quite comfortable with in a new
interview with the West block Mercedes
Stevenson joins us now from Calgary with
more on it Mercedes
tomorrow Jason Kenney is a political
lifer he spent 25 years as an elected
politician and has never been defeated
in a general election but in an ironic
reversal of Fortunes he was attacked by
his own caucus and party politically
hobbling him resulting in a leadership
review and ultimately his decision to
step down from politics
in a broadcast exclusive interview Jason
Kenney raised the alarm about the future
of conservatism what he calls populism
with a snarl a not so veiled reference
to incoming Premier Danielle Smith Kenny
says the lack of Civility dominating
politics and politicians willingly
catering to conspiracy theories is
dangerous for conservatism and the
country he believes that coveted
conspiracies have had a devastating
impact on his ability to govern and
manage his caucus he fears that those
conspiracy theories are now feeding a
deep alienation cutting some albertans
off from appeals based in fact or Reason
and he's not sure how to come back from
that I found through covet an inability
to communicate
basic facts to a certain element of the
population and I don't know how to
remedy that well Danielle Smith appealed
to the more radical elements of what
Kenny called Q anon-like conspiracy
theories in her campaign the question is
if she will now moderate to appeal to a
broader cross-sectional of albertans
whatever is next for Premier design Nick
Danielle Smith it is clear that her main
target will be Ottawa and prime minister
Justin Trudeau the provinces are now
beginning to realize that we are not a
subordinate level of government to
Ottawa and Ottawa should be treating us
with the same respect that they treat
Quebec that's all we're asking for
there's no question that there is anger
in Alberta for Smith to tap into in a
province where many have felt ignored
and disrespected but several of Smith's
promises exceed the power of a premier
their Federal territory the question now
is whether the appeal of a champion
against Ottawa will be enough to see the
UCP re-elected in May or does Smith run
the risk of using the same rhetorical
Gambit that got Jason Kenney in trouble
making promises without deliverables and
facing an outraged electorate pharah
Mercedes Stevenson in Calgary thank you
Mercedes and you can watch the whole
interview with Jason Kenney on the west
block tomorrow morning right here on
global
I had breaking barriers meet the
Canadian medical association's first
indigenous president his plans to change
this country's unequal Health Care
system
[Music]
the first indigenous leader of the
Canadian Medical Association is new in
the job but as the president of the
largest group representing doctors in
this country Dr Alika LaFontaine has his
work cut out for him the
anesthesiologist from Grand Prairie
Alberta has spent many years of his
20-year career helping marginalized
Canadians navigate the Health Care
system and advocating for their care
tonight on the new reality Anita Garcia
speaks with Dr LaFontaine and she joins
us now with more nitu when Dr Alika
LaFontaine first stepped into this new
role he wanted to ensure that people in
leadership positions could see the
barriers to health care that so many
Canadians face and because he's dealt
with it firsthand too he knows it's a
deeply ingrained issue in Canadian
medicine the experience of racism Israel
I've experienced it myself I have family
members who've experienced it and once
we can acknowledge that things are real
we can then work towards those solutions
that I think are in the hands of the
people that experience them
adequate Access to Health Care is
something many indigenous peoples face
across the country some even fear seeing
a doctor we have this history in Canada
where we've been taught to look at
indigenous people certain ways and we've
internalized that within the Healthcare
System organizations like the Canadian
Medical Association that have been
around for 155 years you know they're on
their own path towards reconciliation
you know we've never had more indigenous
physicians in this country than we've
had now and we have a lot of people who
you know are acting as allies trying to
create spaces for these conversations 10
tens of thousands of doctors are members
of the Canadian Medical Association the
largest advocacy group in Canada
creating space to talk about inequities
in health care is a step forward I know
what it's like to have your voice
silenced and pushed out and I think
because of that I really have a strong
drive to make sure that people don't
experience those same feelings
because I know how painful that can be
and I I really believe that if people
understand that part of the experience I
think there's a real chance for human
connection there Dr LaFontaine also had
a lot to say about how to fix a
collapsing Health Care system and he
didn't hold back he knows it's going to
be a challenging year in the top job but
when speaking with him and hearing his
stories about how he overcame barriers
to finding success it's clear he's up
for the task ahead pharah
New Westminster BC thank you nitu and
you can catch neethu's full story on Dr
Alika LaFontaine on the new reality
tonight at 7 right here on global
next building boxes for those without
one woman's Thanksgiving tradition
the political stories that matter to
Canadians the West blog with Mercedes
Stevenson Sunday's own global
many families across Canada will find it
difficult to put food on the table this
Thanksgiving but one woman in Calgary is
making a difference one hamper at a time
as Norma Reed reports a setback in her
own life inspired her to help others
stick this stuff out it's a living room
turned turkey Warehouse I have a big
freezer downstairs
and right now very it's full Maria
pokerastu founder of Maria's food and
Pantry Foundation is making a big
difference for dozens of deserving
families this Thanksgiving I've been
there to where some of the families they
are now
and that's why I decided to do it six
years ago she felt helpless after an
unsuccessful surgery left her unable to
walk I was forced to stay home
and I was looking for something to do
today with help from her son Denise
Marcel and friend Charlotte Landry
Maria's dream he's a reality she got it
off the ground and running all by
herself
when she really couldn't do any of the
running
well now she's got people to do the
running so we do more like she says she
hollers we run and it's very important
to be able to help out others who are in
the similar same shoes as my mom
families can apply on her Facebook page
they will pick up a free hamper from her
home filled with everything for
Thanksgiving dinner those wishing to
donate still have time and can reach out
online I am very grateful that I'm able
to do this right now
and I will keep doing it for as long as
I can proving it doesn't take a lot to
make a big impact it's right from the
bottom of our heart Norma Reed Global
News
it's a big heart she has and that's
global national for this Saturday night
I'm far enough sir on behalf of our
whole crew I want to thank you so much
for spending part of your evening with
us tonight's your Canada is in Banff
Alberta we love seeing your Canada so
please keep emailing us your photos to
viewers at globalnational.com until
tomorrow take care of yourselves and
each other good night
foreign
[Music]